joining us on the mercedes-benz van
phone line after that w in santa clara
against the san francisco 49ers is
quarterback colt mccoy how are you colt
hey i'm doing well thank you for having
me on how how'd that feel for yesterday
what was that like for you yesterday it
was great it was great um
anytime you can go on the road in the
division and and come out on top i think
you know those plane rides are pretty
fun on the way home and and for me you
know
it's kind of a crazy week you didn't
didn't know if kyle was going to be able
to go or not i was kind of up in the air
most of the week and
uh just to be able to step in and guys
kind of rally around me you mentioned
james i thought james played outstanding
yesterday made my life a whole lot
easier
the guys up front blocked well i mean
the san francisco's defense is is really
good especially up front
um so
we were we were we were
we were better yesterday we played well
and and uh
you know again to get a win on the road
like that is huge people in my position
uh colt use the word challenge a lot
like what's the challenge in this and
what's your challenge in that but i
imagine uh there's no greater challenge
than trying to prepare for a game that
you don't know that you're actually
going to play in until the last second
how what is the challenge in doing that
cold
yeah well i mean it's kind of a life of
a backup right right now you know you
just you always prepare you never know
most of the times you prepare
you know for a game
where if something were to happen to the
starter you just got to come off the
bench and be ready to go you know this
week i did get some refs in practice but
it was still
kind of up in the air is uncertainty
around kyler you know he's having an
unbelievable season
and he obviously wanted to be out there
and and play and uh so it makes it that
much sweeter that we were able to to
pull through and get a win and kind of
get back on the get back on the winning
streak
and so um
what uh what was it like for you in the
middle of that game i mean again it's
been it's been a minute right so yeah uh
it's it can't be simple to just step
right back in and now you're in the
midst of
um a significant game for you you know
you guys swept a season opponent you
know a division opponent that is
huge um and certainly with a chance to
get a one seed still
so um i i'm wondering what that
sensation is like if you can put us in
your shoes colt mccoy yeah well i mean i
just
i thought cliff did a really good job of
uh
sort of getting me in rhythm early in
the game
we didn't convert on our first third
down but we came off we communicated
well and he kind of knew what i liked
and i kind of knew where where he wanted
to go
with his next few calls and it just i
started i started in a rhythm early and
that that really helped you know our
quarterbacks coach cam turner did a
great job all week of
you know just
we we you know we thought caller was
going to play and then you know as the
week goes on you kind of all right what
do you like on third downs what do you
like in the red zone you kind of start
you know kyle and i like a lot of the
same things but you know maybe i see
something a little bit different i kind
of like this you know we kind of just
detailed that all week and then all of a
sudden it was sunday time to play and
um i'm just yeah i think the guys on
offense did a great job of just kind of
rallying around me i think they had
confidence in me
our defense played lights out again
they've been playing at a really high
level and um even when guys you know
weren't able to play you know you you
wasn't playing with hop or aj
the other guys stepped up and made plays
and and uh
i think i think that's the sign of a
good team and and we just got to keep it
rolling
colt mccoy here on the rich eisen show
and uh kingsbury's out there with the
shades going uh john john with josh
norman
well what the hell happened there
i would i don't know i don't know i knew
that we got a penalty so i was thinking
about how far that field goal was going
to be and then i saw another flag
and all of a sudden we had we had a
first down so i don't i don't know the
whole scuffle um but
kind of crazy tournament events there i
know it's it is it's it's easy to laugh
about it because again it was it's all
good in the hood now that you you came
up with that win what's the sensation
around there colt um about this team and
the belief in it from outside in i know
you might tune it out or anything like
that but i'm
i i noticed j.j wadden nfl films
microphone picked up him sensing that uh
not everyone believes in the cardinals
that you're for real what is that
conversation like within your your
building
yeah i think
uh you know again i'm i'm honored to be
a part of this team i'm excited to be a
part of this team i'm thankful that i
got to play
all those things but i think steve has
done a great job of assembling a group
of guys where there's there's some good
veterans who've been on some good
winning football teams
who have good leadership in the locker
room there's a good mix of young guys
who who are who are playing playing at a
high level making plays
and i think that makes you know of
veterans and young guys is very healthy
we've battled injuries we've lost a
bunch of guys our o-line is banged up
um and so
for us to go in and and play the way we
did and come out on top i think you know
says a lot about how cliff you know
cliff coaches us and believes in us but
at the same time you know i think it's a
really good group of guys who take it
one week at a time you know we don't
really
listen to the outside noise and think
about like what's next we really just
try to hone in and focus on one week at
a time and
um you know i've been on some teams that
don't think that way and
you know
couldn't have really handled a
situation like we did last week right
where we lose on the last play of the
game
you know we're undefeated
and we got to sit on that for three or
four days over that kind of mini buy and
then come back
and get re-energized and ready to go on
the road in the division you know i've
i've been in places where that just
doesn't happen that way right so sure
i'm i'm very proud to be a part of this
team
this is this is a really good group of
guys and um you know i think our main
focus is just figuring out a way to keep
it going so um i guess in that i know
i'm veering out of arlene for a second
colt mccoy but i'll do it and you you
answer how you wish um you you know what
it is like for somebody to be highly
drafted um well third round but 85th
overall out of the big 12 and placed in
cleveland ohio as the hope and uh of a
franchise there do you have any two
cents on on baker mayfield and the the
sort of
difficulty he sometimes gets from folks
in cleveland about not doing enough
and things of that nature just putting
yourself back in the shoes
uh of 2010 2011 and things of that
nature yeah yeah well i'll tell you this
i always have the backs of quarterbacks
especially those guys who play in
cleveland
the fans in cleveland are amazing
all they want is to win
and you know i i think over the last few
years they've done a great job i mean
they
won a playoff game last year so
um
i know in my time in cleveland i gave it
absolutely everything i had and it just
it just didn't work for a lot of
different reasons
um but
there wasn't anybody there that wanted
it more and wanted to see it see it work
so
i think baker's done a great job
again i'll take i'll take
uh
the quarterbacks back all the time
because
playing this position in this league
against these defenses week to week
you know and for baker's sake playing in
the afc north it's tough
um so
i don't know what that means i just know
that you know i i enjoyed my time in
cleveland we just didn't win and when
you don't win in this league it's
you get replaced and and you know i
learned that lesson the hard way and
glad to be glad to be where i'm at right
now yeah year 11 colt for you franchise
five year 11. if i told you on that
draft night you'd play 11 years in the
nfl would you say would you say
i did not know what you know at that
point when i was coming out of college
i didn't know if i was going to get to
play again because of the injury that i
took in the national championship
against alabama i mean i i couldn't
doctors couldn't tell anybody when i was
going to be ready to play if if i was
going to be able to throw again all
those things so i had to i had to live
through that nightmare for a little bit
but
um
you know
once i got into the league i realized
real quickly that this is
this is not college anymore and this is
you gotta figure out how to play play
this game like a pro
and what is what was that challenge
seriously now that you're looking back
on it you you hear all the conversations
going on in the nfl right now about this
guy should start that guy should start i
guess we're kind of all through that
for 2021 with all the starting
quarterbacks and you know there
was another kid across the way from you
yesterday and trey lance waiting for his
chance uh when that comes for san
francisco what it what is the uh now you
look back with
20 20 vision of 11 nfl years
i think i think that for any young
quarterback that comes into the nfl you
know you you were generally the best
player on the field wherever you played
in college whether that was you know
high level college or whether it was
that like you know for trey lance at at
a smaller school and so you you just
were
you would go into games knowing you were
the best player and and making a bunch
of plays and when you come into the nfl
i mean this is the this is the best of
the best
every team you know the teams that have
losing records right now have great
players and they're usually you know
one fumble away or one ball bouncing the
other way away from having a winning
record guys are just they're just good
you can't run around guys anymore lamar
jackson can kyler murray can i can't
um so you got to figure out how to play
in the pocket how to switch protections
how to read defenses
where the ball is supposed to go versus
different coverages you know that that
is a huge
learning curve and you know fortunately
i worked really hard and i'm still able
to get to play this kids game that i
really love
um but it takes a lot a lot of work and
a lot of energy and a lot of effort and
a lot of time to to really kind of
figure that out well colt mccoy you had
you set a career mark um for completion
percentage the highest completion
percentage you've ever had in your 11
seasons in the nfl
22 of 26. um after the game coach
kingsbury lauded you saying that's how
you prepare every day called you a
consummate professional he knows where
he's going with the ball he gets it out
quick and gets us
in the right play protected the ball all
day which we knew we had to do i'm gonna
read the next sentence to see where it
lands with you
quote i'm happy for the university of
texas fans because after that game
yesterday at least they can find some
solace in that
your
apparently i mean i guess he's texas
tech forever i understand in a way but
um what are your thoughts on that
they have to take their shots when they
can you
know man i don't mean to stir things up
with you and your coach um
no but i do feel like you know uh i
should give you a chance to retort
based on what he said and lauding you
and your performance and that big win
for you and this franchise and for the
team but uh
why do you have to go all
horns down like that i'll tell you what
cliff is one of a kind he's one of my
favorite coaches
he's he he did a great job i felt like
again he and cam of you know getting
getting me in a rhythm early and then
just and then calling plays and you know
we were executing um
i i love playing in the system in this
offense but you know cliff will always
be a texas tech guy and i'll always be a
texas guy okay just like tyler murray
will always be an oklahoma guy there's
there's just constant jabs going on
around the building but he he had his
moment up there last night
i mean honestly you had your moment in
the sun why is it going to do you like
that has
it's all in good nature have you been to
the kingsbury lair have you been to that
spot that we got a glimpse in during the
draft a couple years ago i've just seen
pictures like you guys i know they're
putting it right up there there is
without his socks on and his loafers
like he's in a he's in a cologne ad you
know he's got that working
you know cliff is the man this is the
man i agree i totally agree
but i i found that funny i wanted to
give you your your your chance to
respond colton i'm glad i did oh that's
good good stuff thanks for the call cult
congrats on that w uh any any sense on
on next week any sense for you right now
on on where things stand maybe for the
next cardinals game for you no i don't i
mean i
i think we'll just we'll kind of um
circle the wagons kind of we lost some
guys last week we're kind of down on
offensive line a little bit we lost
chase
so we're we're
gonna have the next man up
you know mentality and you know i think
kyle will be ready to go and
we'll see what happens colt mccoy
congrats on that let's uh let's stay in
contact really appreciate you taking the
time on the monday after a big dub thank
you okay thanks guys that's colt mccoy
everybody right there on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here